on ne sait pas encore exactement quand
et combien c'est de ces chars vont
arriver sur le territoire ukrainien ce
que l'on sait c'est qu'ils sont très
légers en réalité on parle de char mais
ils sont montés sur roues et non pas et
bien sur sur chaîne c'est cher donc des
véhicules blindés légers en réalité ont
une force c'est qu'ils sont très rapides
très agile ce sont des chars de
reconnaissance d'observation mais en cas
de confrontation avec l'ennemi ils ont
une capacité de riposte de riposte et
ils peuvent être armés ils auront besoin
pour cela de munitions 205 mm d'obus 205
mm alors c'est la première limite
peut-être à la fois une turc de ces
armes puisqu'il va falloir avoir des
munitions du côté ukrainien il va
falloir également former les équipes
mais si cela est fait assez rapidement
les Ukrainiens espèrent en tout cas que
cela pourra servir pour une éventuelle
contre-offensive dans le don base vous
avez parlé en introduction d'une
possible négociation selon la Russie si
l'Ukraine et bien admet la réalité des
nouveaux territoires c'est à dire
concrètement si l'Ukraine accepte que
les quatre régions annexées dont le
Dombas et bien le soir de manière
effective et qu'il perde ses territoires
c'était absolument pas le cas l'Ukraine
ne veut absolument pas laisser ni le
don-basse ni la police Jani Helson elle
veut même récupérer la Crimée alors ça
pourrait être l'occasion de récupérer
ces territoires lors d'une
contre-offensive la limite c'est
évidemment la météo car ici les
températures sont assez douces et tant
qu'il n'aura pas gelé et bien impossible
pour l'armée ukrainienne de mener une
contre-offensive avant et bien peut-être
l'été